oh
God
[Music]
the power of the Lord is here that's
right I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's January 20th 2023 we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
if you want to join us in the community
for questions comments and other
thoughts and such join us at
reubenreport.locals.com we're actually
doing a Community Q a today but we will
start I figured we had to finish the
week the way we started the week with
just a new destruction and implosion and
attack an assault on these World
economic Forum nut jobs so let's just
get right into it so Klaus Schwab you
all know Klaus Schwab he is in charge of
this world economic Forum he has the
scariest accent ever you know David said
something interest to me interesting to
me he was watching one of my Clips he
doesn't watch much of what I do here
because he hears me Babble on about this
stuff during dinner so he doesn't need
to watch the show uh but he saw a clip I
guess somewhere of me talking about
Cloud Schwab and he said you know Klaus
Schwab's accent is like a it's almost
like a cartoon version of if you were
trying to come up with the scary evil
villain accent so we always say he's
like a cartoon villain he's like
Palpatine but are there other people
that have the exact same accent as Klaus
Schwab I don't think so I think they
created him to have the scariest most
obviously ridiculous accent possible
anyway Klaus Schwab is at the wef and he
gets to you know he not only gives the
opening speech and he gets to eat all
the fancy food but he goes on these
panels and he's very very excited about
this it's very nice to see an excited
megalomaniac he's very excited that
they're going to implant microchips in
our brains and know everything that
you're thinking videotape a medical and
biological progress and advancing very
fast but
can you imagine that in 10 years when we
are sitting here we have an implant in
our brains
and I can immediately feel because you
all will have implants I can and we
measure your your brain waves and I can
immediately tell you how some people
react or I can feel how the people react
to your answers is it imaginable
Klaus Klaus I don't need an implant to
figure out how I react to what you're
saying you're evil I don't want your
implant nobody wants your implant do the
people even in that audience want his
implants so that when they listen to him
they can all collectively think about
who likes what he said and who doesn't
like what he said these people want to
take us down to a road of cybernetic
hell I do not want to be locked into
their Matrix and have my carbon body
used as a battery I don't think you do
either but what's more interesting about
it isn't like I like all the Sci-Fi
stuff like I like thinking about those
things and there are incredibly cool
things on the horizon I'm not
anti-science I'm not anti-technology by
any by any measure you know there are
wild things happening right now and you
can't stop science one way or another
you have to hopefully respect it
hopefully look at it in a holistic way
and what was the line the other line
from Jurassic Park they they were so
concerned about how they never asked why
or is that they were so concerned about
why they never asked how what was that
line somebody help me on this one they
were so concerned about
how wait we got to get this one right
Jeff Goldblum they were so concerned
about whether they could they never they
should have asked whether they shouldn't
come out we could do this together guys
they were so
they were so concerned about whether or
not they could
they never stopped to think if they
should
that's teamwork right there
and that's what these people are doing
right like okay yes maybe we'd be able
to implant chips in people's brains
maybe we can so we could uh but should
we are we going to be happier after is
any of this making us any happier but
again I'm not anti-science you know you
could take let's say a woman who is
completely infertile right like her her
uterus will not allow for a pregnancy
and now you could have artificial wombs
outside of the body like there's
something interesting there there's
there's ethical issues I get all those
things but like we shouldn't be fearing
the future in that way but we should be
fearing the people who want to steer us
into a future that is more controlled
because once you swallow the pill that
has the uh experimental chip in it or
they inject it into you or they Lodge it
in your brain or they bash you in the
face with it or whatever they do it will
be about controlling you obviously so if
you want to understand how it will be
about controlling you when Klaus is very
excited that you know people in the
audience he'll immediately know what
they're thinking because he said
something and then some weirdo light
goes off in his brain
former British Prime Minister Tony Blair
he's another one he's a big globalist
too he's another one at the world
economic Forum uh and uh he wants to
bring the digital infrastructure to your
country so that they can monitor whether
you've been vaccinated or not
you need to know who's been vaccinated
and who hasn't been some of the vaccines
that will come on down the line will be
multiple there'll be multiple shots so
you've got to have the reasons to do
with the healthcare more generally but
certainly for a pandemic or for
and for vaccines you've got to have a
proper digital infrastructure and many
countries don't have that in fact most
countries don't have that no you don't
Tony you little Mickey Mouse looking
weirdo no you don't uh you don't have to
have that how insane is it that as we
are literally right now
every day we find out more and more
about how the vaccines didn't work how
there are all sorts of vaccine injuries
and heart problems and everything else
shouldn't that be what they're talking
about like if these people really cared
about the world they really cared about
Humanity wouldn't they be talking about
boy we have Albert borla here from
Pfizer we've got the moderna guy and
we've got all these world leaders who
you know locked people at home and
forced people out of jobs and you know
didn't let Grandma die peacefully with
the family around her we just threw her
through a ditch in the name of science
or something you wouldn't they be going
guys let's have a meeting to see what we
did wrong here see how it is possible
that these giant pharmaceutical
companies screwed up everything and lied
to everybody and that our communication
and they could even do it in a way that
wasn't all blaming on them they could
say boy we never faced anything like
covet before and we all got a little
ahead of ourselves or whatever but
instead they're trying to figure out
more ways to control us after the next
magical pandemic comes and they did
learn a lesson they really did learn a
lesson during the last pandemic that
people will behave and not only will
people behave as they wish people will
rat out their neighbors people will
punch strangers remember all the videos
during the height of cover these were my
favorite videos when you see someone at
a store someone's not wearing a mask and
then the masked person is chasing the
not masked person to tell tattletail on
them like they're so supposed to be so
afraid of covid wouldn't you be running
the other way generally
you know at the height of it I think I
told the story once when we were still
living in La I was at Costco at Costco
during covet was just
particularly like Costco is always sort
of like a very crazy place to be in
general but it was like particularly
nutty because everyone was just trying
to get as much as they possibly
could and I was trying to buy a brisket
and I'm standing there and they got a
lot of meat and I'm in the brisket thing
and you had to wear a mask and I walked
in without the mask I got yelled at I
put the mask on but I always put it
beneath my nose and sometimes even
beneath my mouth and I'm looking at the
brisket and the things beneath my nose
and this woman comes up to me and she's
like you know dumbass doesn't work if
it's beneath your nose and I was like oh
is that right thank you so much thank
you lady thank you and then I didn't I
didn't move it up and then she gave me
like the evil eye and the evil eye when
you also have a mask on is like a double
evil eye because you may ask you it was
all so bananas horrible but anyway
Klaus Schwab wants to inject something
in your brain and then this little
Mickey Mouse guy wants the government to
be able to track all of your updated
vaccines do you think that is to free
you do you think that is because they
care about you and want to keep you safe
from diseases or do you think it's
because they want to control you what do
you think you'll win a prize if you get
it uh but it continues here's video of
the director of the FBI right now his
name's Christopher Ray he's over there
not sure what he's doing there I thought
he was supposed to be over here in
America I'm sure we have something he
could be doing right some pushing papers
across the desk or something but here he
is talking about how private and public
collaboration has made great strides to
basically watch us and I think the the
sophistication of the private sector is
is improving and and particularly
important the level of collaboration
between the private sector and the
government especially the FBI has I
think uh made significant strides pretty
much every technology we could talk
about today
we see both great opportunity but great
great dangers uh in the wrong hand I
have to say that I wish that the
director of the FBI wasn't evil that's
not a fun thing you know the director of
the FBI but there he is basically saying
that everything that we've talked about
here for months related to Elon Musk who
is completely against the wef by the way
and making fun of it every day on
Twitter that everything that he has
released with the Twitter files is true
that there is a public private
partnership
the FBI is involved and they are
interested in stifling misinformation
which is really also known as truth and
that they're working together and it
seems to be getting stronger and he's
very happy about it that seems as the
kids say problematic let's do a little
Reuben report Community Q a for you
Daniel says have you heard about the
hockey player that didn't want to wear a
rainbow jersey during warm-ups on Pride
night in Philadelphia the reaction on
Twitter is the Seinfeld episode where
Kramer refuses to wear the ribbon yes I
did hear about this the guy obviously
should not be forced to wear the thing
and he was willing to play in the game
from what I understand he just didn't
want to wear the pin you shouldn't have
to be forced to wear anything you should
be forced to wear an American flag pin
and you shouldn't be forced to wear a
BLM pin or a gay pen a gay brooch I
guess would be better than a pin uh you
just shouldn't be forced to wear any of
these things obviously he has his own
beliefs he does it he said I respect
everybody that's what the guy said he
said I respect everybody I respect
everyone I have my own personal
religious beliefs and I'm just not going
to participate in this that should be
completely fine but they want as they
want with everything they want your
complete
capitulation they want you to live on
your knees forever there's a funny gay
joke there you can make it yourself
that's what these people want and you
should not bow to them you could
probably figure out a gay joke there too
it just never ends with these puns
um yes and it is the rainbow uh sorry it
is the uh flag no not the rainbow frog
yeah the rainbow ribbon it's the ribbon
it is the ribbon episode of Seinfeld
where he goes to the AIDS March and he's
there he's like I'm here I'm supporting
but he just doesn't want to wear the
Ruby you must wear the ribbon it
literally is that episode come to real
life uh it is life imitating art
imitating Life Tony says uh what kind of
hair products do you use to get that
amazing look
Phoenix do you think I can give them the
full hair breakdown should I unleash the
kraken on these people and tell them uh
I will tell you one thing one little
secret well first off since I've been
here in Florida I have not been thrilled
with my stylist I haven't until a few
weeks ago I brought in an Italian
stylist from California who's hopefully
moving here to Florida maybe one of
these days great haircut I'm feeling
very good about the hair right now uh
and now we've got someone else coming in
that's all I can say about that right
now I've been sworn to secrecy but we
have a standing every third Monday
haircut for me here but I will say one
thing I use a dry texturizing spray and
that's what's going to give you the umph
that's what's going to give you there's
a school of thought out there that says
you should be using more gel and I'm
going to take it under your advice but
we're going to talk about it but that's
what I have to say about that Michaela
says hey Dave I'm living in the middle
of Europe watching America hoping that
the lights go on you give me hope do you
feel that we are coming to a watershed
moment concerning the recognition of all
the eyes and fake versus what is really
going on I somewhat feel we are coming
closer they say a lot of invited wef
guests did not come this year or left
early
I mean basically what you're asking is
is there really an Awakening happening
and it's man it's hard it's really hard
to tell like if I was to just go by what
I do here daily for a living and the
life
that I lead in Florida and the people
that I'm around and my audience and the
explosion of growth that we've seen on
the show across every platform and
everything else it's like boy there's a
whole bunch of other people that are
paying attention to a lot of this stuff
and obviously I'm not the only person
talking about these things there are
plenty of other people doing it and and
that's really wonderful right really is
um is there a mass Awakening I think
that something has shifted where
you seem completely ridiculous if you
think that what the mainstream is giving
you is truth I think that that concept
right there has gone sort of mainstream
like if you met someone really think
about this if you just met someone you
know you're sitting at a bar and you
start chatting to the person next to you
do people still do that I used to do
that while ago people still do that you
just start chatting to the guy next to
you and he's like well I was watching
CNN this evening and they played a clip
of Eric swalwell and by golly Uh Kevin
McCarthy's really mean man you'd be like
you're completely insane but it's also
completely insane that anyone would say
that to you or that anyone would admit
watching CNN so I do think something has
turned and I think in some ways that's
why the rhetoric of the wef seems so
crazy because they have to ramp up the
crazy to ramp up the scary it's why the
government's always trying to scare you
about kovid because it's not because
people are tuning out and I think that
maybe the greatest Silver Lining to all
of the lunacy of the last couple years
and all of the coveted craziness is that
people did start thinking about their
lives differently I certainly know that
I did and I put a lot of that into
action and to the ideas of what I talk
about here but literally picking up and
moving across the country and I think a
lot of people are feeling some degree of
that you know this Mass migration thing
all over the country makes people think
about it right why does nobody move to
California why do 1200 people move to
Florida a day a day that's an awful lot
of people it's because people have had
some degree of an Awakening so yeah I
think we have to whether it's fully true
or not I think we have to kind of
believe that it's true so that we can
make it true I think it's something like
that Arnie says do you think if
president Trump goes back on Twitter
people will lose their well it
sounds like Trump's coming back and
apparently he may be allowed back on on
Facebook so he technically is on Twitter
now so when Elon got Twitter he did
unlock the account Trump did not use the
account yet but now over the last couple
days people are saying he is going to
start using it again there are some
questions as to whether legally he can
use it because you know he's got truth
social which is basically a Twitter
clone and he obviously has a lot of
financial interests there and I'm sure
they have some exclusivity things and he
might be battling that out with the
lawyers right now I don't know but as to
whether people will go bananas of course
of course this is going to be proof Elon
bought the thing to allow the white
supremacists to run around and the
orange man is back and Badness is
spreading across the Galaxy yeah they're
going to make everyone freak out and uh
frankly I'd like him back I mean I I
think the generally speaking the more
voices the better and even if there are
genuinely bad people out there and I
obviously don't include Trump in that
they should be on there if you're
directly threatening somebody or you're
posting child porn or something like
that you obviously should not be on
there and they should deal with you uh
according to the law
but if you just want to say mean things
people can block you or mute your ignore
you and that's what it is Amy says if
you knew your time on Earth was up in a
week what would you do with those final
days
do you know something I don't know uh
was that a threat Amy
um what would I do what would I do I
mean really I guess I would just uh well
I'd probably keep doing the show you
guys want to do the show if this is it
if we got one week left yeah
sometimes on the weekends we come back
I'm like Mike Phoenix how was the
weekend he's like I really wanted to go
to work you want to start working on the
weekends I can't be here but you could
be here yeah I guess I would kind of do
the show I'd talk you guys through the
end of the world I'd probably have the
kids with me that would be fun I could
have Justin here and Luke here we could
do like a different kind of show as the
world came to an end that would be but
what else what else am I going to do
like I'd get in the pool I guess uh
maybe
you know oh you know what I would do
I've got a Japanese A5 wagyu rib eye
sitting downstairs in the garage in our
so we have a chest of breast milk and
there is one piece of meat in there
David put that wagyu in there because he
knew that if he put a frozen wagu in
there that I would go in there and make
sure that the breast milk was not
defrosting all the time that you know we
didn't have like a power shortage and
that thing was out so I do go in there
once a day I check on my wagu and I make
sure the breast milk is frozen so I
would eat the wagu I'd have the kids
here we do a show
and I guess we drink some tequila X
house says hey Dave you seem pretty
business savvy for a comedian did you go
to college if so what school and what
did you study congrats on all the local
success thanks you know the business
part of me is is sort of bizarre in a
way because I did not think I was going
to be a businessman in any way and I
ended up running two pretty freaking
successful companies which is odd but I
guess an extension of just the stuff
that I talk about here and I just kind
of built things that I felt were
necessary to be built and I was like why
doesn't other people why don't other
people build these things and then I was
like nobody's doing it I guess I'll do
it right like that that's something
that's really how locals started
especially
um I did go to college I went to SUNY
Binghamton in New York SUNY State
University of New York at Binghamton
Binghamton is generally considered uh
the best state school in New York so it
was very cheap to get into it was like
nine grand a year or something like that
and my dad was very clear to me said I
remember I was I guess a junior in high
school and I kind of wanted to go to
Syracuse Syracuse is actually up in
Upstate New York kind of about an hour
away from Binghamton and I want to go to
serious because I wanted to be a sports
broadcaster I wanted to be on like
sports center or something like that and
Mark Albert had gone there and I think
Bob Costas went there and a bunch of
SportsCenter guys went there and uh it
was like it was like 25 Grand a year and
now it's something like 65 Grand a year
and my dad was clear he was like look if
you go to a state school I don't care
which one you go to but if you go to a
state school we'll take care of the bill
but if you go to a private school it's
on you I think he said that they would
cover the State School portion of it
like so they'd throw nine grand to it
something like that but I'd have to
cover the rest and I was like all right
I'm going to go to the state school I
was a poli-sci major at Binghamton
University believe it or not now I did
come out of Lefty so I'm not sure how
great the education was I probably
smoked a little too much pot to be quite
Frank terrible glaucoma up there in
Upstate New York
um but uh but then I made it out and
then somehow along the way I had my
political Awakening started talking
about the things that I cared about
people like you guys started watching
and then and then the locals thing was
really like we've got a problem here
with big Tech I'm going to build
something and uh as I've said many times
you know had I known how difficult it
was going to be and the amount of hours
I was going to spend on it and the
fundraising and the traveling and the
zoom calls repeating the same things
over and over and over to all these
people so you could raise funds to keep
the company going for another day and
having to throw my own money in and you
don't do anything at a startup you're
not making money for a long time uh I
don't even know that I would have done
it but we did it and and it worked
obviously we merged with Rumble and
we've built something that's really
cooking right now so it's awesome uh
Kelly says how is it that the media and
Hollywood celebs are all liberal I get
that they aren't the sharpest tools in
the shed but do you think they're all
actually okay with what's happening in
the country they do see we are going to
hell in a handbag right you know first
off
I don't know that they're all actually
liberal in that sense right like I think
that most of them are let's say socially
liberal sure so they're liberal in in
let's say the regards of gay marriage or
something which again nobody cares about
anymore or or maybe they're more liberal
on on let's say abortion right those
would be the big two but in terms of how
they live their lives you think that
Hollywood Rich Hollywood celebrities
like paying taxes trust me they are
doing everything possible every trick in
the book to make sure that they are
paying the least amount of taxes I think
most of them unfortunately what happens
is you know the cult of celebrity
creates a certain set of people that
don't really think about the big issues
they just want to be liked more than
anything else you know Adam Carolla was
on my show and had a good line about
this and Adam Adam's more entrenched he
still lives in La more entrenched in
Hollywood than I ever was even though I
did live there what he said was you know
if you're an actor
and even if you're a comic a pretty good
comic and Comics are more a dime a dozen
than an actor you know you can be
replaced very easily like there's
there's no actor that can't be replaced
if you took uh Tom Hanks you know
Forrest Gump it's like he was pretty
damn good in Forrest Gump but if Tom
Hanks had been unavailable they could
have got Harrison Ford right they could
have and it would have been roughly the
same movie something like that these
people are all replaceable so what
happens is when you have a whole bunch
of people that they don't really produce
anything uh not to say that they aren't
talented they're Obviously good actors
and they're obviously brilliant singers
and and musicians and artists and all
that but when you take a bunch of people
that are very replaceable they will
always give to the system what the
system wants because you can't fight the
system when you know that you're a
replaceable part of that system so that
was another reason that I really wanted
to get the hell out of LA and you know
stop working with agents and all that
stuff I was just like it's not that it
was all inherently evil it was just like
I don't need that I would rather build
my own thing so I don't know that
they're all
uh super Lefty liberal I think they just
play it up for that and by the way there
are plenty of Hollywood conservatives I
mean you know of some right whether it's
Gary Sinise or Jon Voight or you know
some other people Rob Schneider a couple
other people but there are plenty of
others that are on the DL and the
problem is they're on the DL because
they feel like they're not going to get
work if you got it uh Snow Baby Says is
there a milestone you're looking forward
to with the boy the boys reaching if
they have not already what is it I was
excited first for the giggles and laugh
they're now I'm looking forward to the
wee one walking on their own oh it
sounds like you have kids about the same
age
um I mean the Laughing thing is great
like Justin is just laughing constantly
and in the last couple days Luke is
starting to laugh and I'm doing all
sorts of silly things with him I never I
don't baby talk them but I do a lot of
funny accents with them and I kind of
poke and prod and moving around and put
it and I build a lot of pillow for it
I'm very good at pillow for its blanket
forts I'm going to be very good at that
sort of you know we got some kind of
we're under attack the aliens are coming
to get us we got to build a fort that
thing
um is there anything I'm looking forward
to I guess that those first few words
you know like I guess Dada that that
would be a good one on the Milestone
front like that'll that'll really be
something
um but right now it's like they're
they're really in a good Zone and and
they're healthy most importantly and
they're happy and it's a lot uh you know
it's the sleeping isn't great and for us
at least I think it's okay for them
um but yeah it's all good uh Margot says
you've shown that you have a very
practical nature but we all have our own
vision of a perfect world that being
said what's your version of Utopia
especially for you and your family well
unfortunately I don't believe in in a
true Utopia like that we can as a
society get to a place that everything
is this perfect Utopia I think
unfortunately on the way to that you end
up with dystopia right like all of the
people at the world economic Forum they
want to get us to this digital Utopia
where you'll own nothing and and be
happy or something and I just don't
believe that exists however I do believe
happiness exists and you can have these
brief moments in life when you get it
and I think in the last couple weeks
I've seen a a new version of that like
almost a it's something like my life was
like a little black and white before
these kids and now it's like coming into
full color like there's there's
something that I can't quite explain but
if you're a parent I suppose you
probably get it it's like an unsaid
thing you just start realizing there is
a richness here you could see the world
in a little bit of a better way I think
I've been a little bit better on the
show actually because I'm seeing things
a little bit differently I also feel
that the fight is worth having a little
bit more because I have to fight for
something Beyond me like there's a lot
of that kind of stuff
um but a perfect day is uh well at the
moment I'll give you a perfect day on a
Saturday right now a perfect day is if
the kids take good naps and that means I
can get one nap and David could get one
nap and uh and I get to cook a nice meal
at night and we could hang out in the
hot tub and I can have a little sipping
tequila and we take a nice walk with AI
like that's good enough for me I don't
need anything else I really don't uh hey
Dave what is your advice to one of your
sons when they come to you in 20 years
and say Dad I want to be a stand-up
comedian oh man
you sick son of a
um
it's a tough life it's a tough tough
life I mean I don't know that stand-up
comedy in that in the way we know
stand-up comedy now will even exist then
like the Way digital things are and that
anyone can become famous overnight with
this thing like maybe that art will you
know I think spoken word art will always
exist as long as humans are allowed to
speak which is very contrary to what the
WF is pushing these days
um but well I'll put it this way I would
hope that whatever my kids said to me
you know I want to be a stand-up
comedian or I want to be a doctor or I
want to be a ditch digger I hope I would
encourage them to follow what their
dreams are I I hope that I'll be able to
do that like I hope it's not something
that's so I hope they're not like Daddy
I want to be a diversity equity and
inclusion therapist that would be a
problem Daddy I want to be a drag queen
for kids that would be a problem give me
one more what would be another one I
wouldn't be happy with Daddy I want to
be a professional soccer player I
wouldn't like that either I don't like
soccer but beyond that it's like yeah I
would hope that whatever they came to me
with that I would
I hopefully I would be interested enough
to want to help the journey whatever
that means and I've given them the tools
to go out and do it Sweetwater says
what's your favorite conspiracy theory
that you're reasonably sure is not true
um you know it's funny I've been
watching a lot of what wait what do you
have what
oh
we actually all have a friend who we
went to dinner with not too long ago who
was like the most bananas conspiracy
theorist ever and was saying stuff that
if I was even to say on this show I
would be removed from Human Society
altogether a conspiracy theory one of
them is
um you know I could do like the aliens
and all that stuff but like who really
built the pyramids uh I went to Egypt to
Cairo in I think 1997 I was 21 years old
uh spent a couple days in Cairo and you
go to these pyramids and when you see
the the the massive blocks that they
built and the height of these things and
that you think they did this thousands
of years ago
how the hell did they do this now if you
were to I think a lot of people think
that basically it's the story of
Passover it's the story of the Bible the
Hebrews did this thing right the slaves
were doing it but the idea that even if
there were hundreds of thousands of
slaves all pulling these like how the
hell did they do and there's all sorts
of theories on how they moved the uh the
blocks and all that stuff some people
say it is the aliens using some sort of
magnet technology to move the things and
all that but if it was the Hebrews it's
kind of fun to think that my like great
great great great great great great
great great grandfather was you know out
there pulling the block building the
pyramid something like that
Kathy says have you started writing your
third book what will the general theme
be I haven't started yet uh I've
scribbled down a couple ideas and a
couple notes and the thing is when I'm
when I'm traveling more that's usually
when I have a little more time to write
and like sketch out the ideas and all
that and obviously with the kids I
haven't been traveling as much I've done
a little bit of stuff here in Florida
um so I haven't really put it all
together yet but there will be a third
book for sure if anything I miss the
touring more than anything else like I
loved loved loved being on the road last
year like it was just so great it was
also because that was when the country
was really just opening up and they got
masks off the planes and all that stuff
and just being out there and seeing
people again it was great
um so yeah we're
I got it I gotta figure it out can you
put it in my calendar write a book okay
thanks uh Florida man Chuck says have
you watched the Tim pool interview with
Matt Gates if so what was the most
surprising thing to learn you must have
missed our show on I think it was
Tuesday or Wednesday this week we played
a couple clips of that yeah so Matt
Gates Congressman uh from Florida he was
on Tim Poole's podcast they did like
their their two-hour thing uh and there
were a couple Great Clips in there where
he really talks about the underbelly of
how DC works or does not work depending
on which way you look at it and I think
that look overall I would say Gates has
done a nice job being The Outsider in
the system right like he I think has
pushed McCarthy to probably be a little
bit better in the simple fact is
McCarthy is being better right now the
Republicans are pushing the right thing
just a few little things you know as you
know they're getting rid of the 87 000
IRS agents they're cutting the funding
on them they're opening up the house
again so people can get back in there
and watch the debates we're going to do
a locals event there we're going to
announced that we're going to DC we'll
meet a whole bunch of you we'll go to
the Capitol I'll see if we can get a
meeting with McCarthy or maybe Jim
Jordan or Ted Cruz or somebody maybe a
couple people we'll do a lunch we'll
spend a day in DC we'll go to The
Monuments all that stuff I can't wait to
do that so stay tuned if you're if
you're in the local community
um he's having members they have to come
back and vote right no more proxy voting
no more vote by text than any other
stuff they're starting to look into
China right so they are starting to do
things and I think a lot of that comes
from the gates wing of this that we have
to be a little more hardcore so I think
that's totally good Justin says what is
at the core of the people's Blind Eye of
the Biden family's corruption
you know I think a lot of things are
that people are just trying to live
their lives people think that politics
is so whacked and in some respects
they're so right that there's no
conspiracy or Scandal or nonsensical
event at this point that could shock you
like what could shock you anymore if you
woke up tomorrow morning and they were
like actually it turns out that yes Joe
Biden is a lizard person he was given a
speech and his skin was a little dry
that day and his face fell off and there
was a lizard person under there and
we've been under the rule of lizard
people would it be that shocking
it wouldn't be right so I think part of
it is that everything is so nutty that a
lot of people are just checked out
um and I think the other thing is that
you know way too many people
unfortunately and we all know them uh
they they made their whole world view
sort of if Trump believes one thing I
believe something else so I think that
that still sits with people so right now
even though they think most people think
that Biden has some level of Dementia or
something most people think he's not
really competent doesn't really know
what's going on most people think the
radical left has gone too far
but because they they've decided to
Define everything by Trump behind that
they just let it fly they just let it
slide I think it becomes a blind spot to
them it's it's uh it's why you have to
believe in something other than politics
and then and then politics can fit
within whatever you believe because
otherwise you will just be endlessly
crazy and you will be crazily partisan
and it's funny because look I'm I'm a
registered Republican since I'm here in
Florida obviously I think the
Republicans are a much better party
obviously I think most conservative
ideas are better than whatever the
leftist nonsense of the day is but in a
weird way I don't consider myself
partisan at all I I'm actually not truly
partisan I have differences with
Republicans for sure and as I always say
the Republicans will fail us too so you
want to you want to support people uh
based on an honest position and an
assessment of the issues not just
because they got the the r or the D next
to their name uh Nate says Dave can you
tell us if locals Rumble slash Reuben
report has any plans to get in into the
original content arena-like feature
films for example yes absolutely we do
and we've done a couple things you know
Dinesh D'Souza released 2 000 mules
first on locals and he did incredibly
well there I mean millions and millions
of dollars tons of people bought it
there uh I released my first stand-up
special on locals we're releasing more
docs on locals we're trying to figure
out how to go a little more into that
direct content thing where basically
each person's locals Community would
give you access to a whole other set of
a whole other library of content whether
it's documentaries or series or
stand-ups or movies whatever it might be
we're building out a lot of those things
and and trust me the the rumble team is
working on uh re-hauling the the UI over
there
which as you've probably noticed has
already gotten better we've updated a
whole bunch of things in the locals app
now so you can watch the show live
within locals and comment at the same
time and we're we're working on a whole
bunch more so I know it takes time A lot
of people have asked us about bundling
it's just been extremely complex to do
um technically but we're working on that
as well uh and just uh just stay tuned
we're going to keep doing good things I
appreciate all you use that all of yous
who drop questions uh this week I cannot
do a post game show today because I got
a thing I gotta run I'll make it up to
you next week with some bonus minutes I
promise you uh and we leave you
with the elderly man pretending to be
president have a nice weekend the number
of bullets can go in a magazine there's
no no need
for any of that I love my right-wing
friends to talk about the tree of
Liberty as water or the blood of
patriots
come here if you need to work about
taking on the federal government you
need some f-15s you don't need an RAR
15. I'm serious think about it
thank you